hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast ten and biomedical
revealing new solutions prevented
presented by dr. Brian McNally we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by labyrinth and
sponsored by Canon biomedical canon
biomedical a wholly owned subsidiary of
Canon USA Incorporated is focused on
empowering the biomedical research and
health care communities by developing
manufacturing and marketing innovative
technologies and solutions the
technologies and solutions developed
will help the neighbor clinicians and
scientists to improve our health and
advance science for more information
please visit www com lame Julie O'Rourke
elaborate and I'll be your moderator for
today's event before I begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over and to get your credits
click on the cee button located in the
bottom left hand corner of your web page
also please notice that you will be
viewing the presentation in the slide
window to enlarge the window just click
on the screen icon located on the lower
right if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the support button at the top right of
the presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem now I'd like to introduce dr.
Brian McNally brian has 15 years
practical experience at the laboratory
bench and his work has been published in
peer-reviewed journals and presented at
international conferences in 2008 he
transitioned to industry to
commercialize new biomedical products
including assays reagents and software
brian has been with kennan biomedical
since its inception last year
is passionate about partnering with life
scientists to develop the next wave of
biomedical solutions please join me in
welcoming Bryant I will now turn the
presentation over to him
great thank you very much for the kind
introduction so I'm really excited to be
sharing at our first conference with
elaborate sore for spiritual conferences
canon biomedical as Judy mentioned we're
a brand new company but we have a very
familiar logo that we'll talk about a
little bit but I did want to get started
with a couple of disclaimers and notices
one any of the solutions that I show
today are going to be from Canon
BattleMech Laura for research use only
they are not for use in diagnostic
procedures for those of you that request
current licensing information and
product disclaimers we have product
specific user manuals and documentation
on our website that was mentioned canon
dash biomedical calm or it can be
requested from mchana biomedical
representative and will provide that
information at the end of today's talk
the product said I'll show you during
the course of today's presentation are
currently only available in the United
States as of May fourth 2016 that's not
to say forever that's just for today and
I'll go ahead and move on to the agenda
for today so some of you might be
wondering I've seen that logo before you
know that looks like a camera logo or a
printer logo so what is can enjoy matlab
roots and so we'll talk a little bit
about that and then we'll talk about
cannons interest in genetics
specifically human genetics and then the
most of the majority of the talk will
really be focused around then how
individual scientists should go about
selecting genotyping technologies which
benefit which particular ones are
advantageous for their experimental use
and we'll focus on the benefits of
high-resolution melting and then at the
end I'll conclude by discussing a little
bit about the noble assays and
chemistry's as an introduction so cannon
at lab root so you might be wondering if
I was going to talk about maybe cameras
that are going to be hooked up to your
microscope and it's not what I'm going
to be talking about so I was actually
kind of curious if we could launch the
first poll i was curious how many of you
have heard of Kingdom biomedical
previously
so so if you just want to go ahead and
click on the yes or no button that'd be
really great so as was indicated during
the course of the introduction Kanan
biomedical was actually founded last
year in march of 2015 and then we lost
your very first product in September of
2015 and have continued to release
additional products since then okay so
so we're actually not really uh offering
cameras or my uh for your microscope in
fact though cannons though does have a
long history in biomedical applications
and this is actually cannons first CEO
mr. dr. Miller I'm dr. Miller I I was as
you can see a medical doctor I was a
gynecologist and was the first cannon
president and in 1940 you can see there
a picture on the right was the first
indirect x-ray camera that was offered
in Japan that was offered by cannon so
candidates had a long interest in
biomedical applications and medical
history some people that know for
instance the areas of ophthalmology are
aware of some of the products that are
in ophthalmology to support the
knowledge is diagnosing glaucoma but
we're really at this point now beginning
to return to our roots and as you can
see from this slide this is now our
current chairman and CEO mr. Miller I
who's actually related to dr. Miller I
and in 2013 there was an article that
was published here and the Nikkei news
that cannon was going to begin making
viene testers in the United States and
that medical devices would become a new
product area for Canon and so in
beginning to execute that operation
canon biomedical was formed last year
and began to launch our very first
products
and so I'd like to share with you in the
next slide a little bit about through
the background of canons philosophy and
how we'd like to interact with the
research marketplace for instance those
people that are coming to the genetics
and genomics conference so Canada as a
corporation has a philosophy with
virtuous Kia fades symbolized here and
this roughly translates to all people
regardless of race religion or culture
harmoniously living and working together
into the future and if we think about
that statement working together into the
future harmoniously we think about how
that would for instance be embodied by
health care and isn't this a sort of our
you know as a species sort of our common
goal to sort of live their lives and
I've just put some gross statistics
about what's going on in the world as
far as a global aging in the upper
left-hand corner you can see that our
population overall is becoming older
we're living longer but then you can see
that there are chronic diseases that are
occurring either those sending in the
graph in the upper right-hand corner
with increasing obesity rates globally
so each of those curves represents an
individual country and their obesity
rate from starting in the year 2000
heading towards 2020 and then if we look
at the graph on the second line on the
left-hand side you can see that these
are overall chronic disease bird so this
is representative by diseases such as
heart failure diabetes cancer in the
United States and the projected number
of incidents and new cases within our
country and so it is a mutual goal for
us all to be living a healthier and
better lives and that canna biomedical
actively wants to contribute to
improving that lifestyle and so we began
as a company by looking at how we could
help perhaps other companies that are
already actively involved in improving
health and I wanted to show this slide
that shows two of our partners that we
work with one on the left there is
peachy biosystems a company based out of
boston they work on
excess disease testing of a fully
automated sample to answer molecular
diagnostics platform that received fda
clearance in 2014 for a candida fungal
panel and canon biomedical and t2
Biosystems are working together to
co-develop a new test that is focused on
lyme disease subsequent to that we also
had another arrangement that we've been
working with a small company and out of
Ontario Canada called Spartan they have
a device it's pictured in the lower
right there that's a point of need
testing it's a fully automated sample to
answer genotyping platform and it does a
single test for a genetic variant that's
associated with a pharmacogenetic
indication and it's been approved in
Health Canada is a near patient testing
so you can see that canna biomedical
here is working with these other
companies to provide a partner for IP
strategy core technology development
engineering manufacturing and technical
support and this represents our ability
as a corporation at large to reach out
to other companies and assist in the
development of their technologies and
empower them to be more widespread so
that it can all fundamentally improve
health care within the country but at
the same time we have our own interests
here at Cana biomedical and those focus
mainly around the field of Human
Genetics and next week I'm going to
focus on for the rest of today's talk
specifically those genetic variations
that impact the formation of inherited
diseases our reaction to drug
medications or the potential for disease
and so genetic variations of course in
come in a number of different forms for
instance single nucleotide polymorphisms
or snips somatic mutations or so those
are non inherited mutations that are
commonly associated with Francis cancer
examples would be in mutations in egfr
b-raf that would lead to for instance
breast cancer lung cancer of course the
variations can be larger they can be
insertions and deletions and this could
be as small as for instance the
insertion of a single nucleotide
creating a frame
shift or something much larger in the
kilobase range that believes an entire
gene and then of course we have copy
number variations and alterations are
much larger changes and rearrangements
that are structural variations within
the genome and so when scientists begin
sort of thinking about testing for
genetic variation is a number of
research applications that are driving
that need for testing and I've just
listed off a couple here just to kind of
introduce conceptually that for instance
in clinical research there's a lot of
times where there's pre-screening of
individuals so for prospective studies
so including or excluding particular
samples from the study before for
instance spending large amounts of
resources energy time money on for
instance whole genome sequencing you
would perhaps want to pre-screen samples
for inclusion or exclusion there could
be some very functional type work for
instance screening for crisper clone
generation or retrospective studies
where you're going back to samples that
have already been collected and then
applying for instance the new genotypes
of that study to better understand that
population and then of course after
large genome studies for instance those
coming off of for instance snip arrays
array CGH microarray data there's often
a need to then verify that that mutation
indeed was prisoner that snip was
present in a particular sample or set of
samples and now with so many core
laboratories holding for instance the
next generation platforms and wanted to
send those samples off a lot of times
there's a concern and there's a number
of professional organizations have been
formed around the world to ensure that
samples aren't mixed up that they indeed
are reporting back the data with the
original associated sample and so sample
identification can be done using just a
very small number of for instance snips
of I've seen some papers that are
arranged between 18 and 24 sniffs to
uniquely identify a sample to ensure
that the rest of the genomic sequence
that's been provided with that data file
indeed matches the original sample that
you sent off to that core laboratory so
these represent really just examples of
times where you actively have to change
type a sample as a scientist and so when
you then have that need to genotype a
sample you're really than having to
choose well what is the appropriate
technology for the experiment that I
have are you trying to discover new
mutations that are previously
undescribed or you're really testing for
things that are known already do you
have large numbers of samples or just a
handful do they come in all at once do
you have a bio bank to pull from or is
this a rolling study where maybe you'll
only get one or two samples a week it
should like the genotype how much of the
sample rule are you getting you getting
you know a nice 5 mil blood tube or is
this a fleeting amount of sample and
then how much resources are in the
laboratory a lot of people to be able to
process this analyze data and each of
the different factors goes into your
choice as a scientist on what tool you
want to pour our the toolbox to analyze
and genotype your samples so asking
these questions ahead of time helps you
with experimental design selecting the
appropriate technology to then apply to
efficiently get your answer in a
cost-effective nana so what are some of
those technologies that are in your tool
basket and I've listed some of them here
for instance next-generation sequencing
mass spectrometry of sanger sequencing
hydrolysis pro pcr a high-resolution
melting analysis are a number of
technologies that you can pull from to
genotype samples currently and I'd like
to focus on high-resolution melting
analysis I think many people are
familiar with it but before I start that
I'd like to launch another poll I'd like
to know how many of you are currently
using pcr for genotyping analysis so
this will be our second poll if you
could go ahead and click on just yes or
no that'd be really helpful
so I'm I think we're still trying to get
to pull up there we go do genotype by
pcr that's right perfect so if you just
want to go ahead and click on yes or no
that'll be great
perfect so a lot of times it's jeans i
beaned by pcr there's a number of
different methodologies that can be used
and one of which that I've described was
high resolution melting another would be
of course hydrolysis pro there's a
number of other versions of genotyping
by pcr that include for instance
molecular beacons and scorpion probes
and so that's why I wanted to ask my
site on my third pole which is a do you
have you used high-resolution melting
analysis previously so because I'm going
to spend the next couple of slides just
quickly introducing the concepts of
high-resolution melting I just wanted to
get a quick sense of the audience
whether or not you've used
high-resolution melting analysis for
genotyping before so I'm going to put up
my third poll now perfect and this is a
great opportunity to just kind of
understand the sophistication and you
know whether or not I should go ahead
and breathe through HRM or really sort
of explaining a little bit more detail
oh that's great
okay perfect well I certainly appreciate
everybody taking the time to answer
those and so moving into high-resolution
melting announcements for those of you
that are not familiar with this
technique of course you know that as you
increase temperature DNA unwinds and so
you can imagine that if there is a
fluorescent molecule a dye that finds
double-stranded DNA at low temperatures
there would be a duplex of the dye would
bind very nicely and fluoresce but that
if you raise the temperature is shown on
the x-axis here in this figure that the
single that the DNA is going to unwind
leave behind to single strand DNA
molecules and then the dives no longer
bound and there's not a flaw as a
significant fluorescent signal and so
that equilibrium point where half of the
DNA is unwound generates about fifty
percent of the signal that is your
melting temperature and so that's really
sort of the biochemical basis behind
high resolution melting and then it's
really a very simple PCR protocol where
scientists begin by doing DNA extraction
in this particular case we strongly
recommend that samples be prepared using
the same protocol and reagents so that
there is a similar salt concentrations
in the resulting DNA isolate and then
moving on then you prepare a reaction
mixture much like a traditional PCR
reaction using the same amount of DNA
and then you add in a master mix perhaps
mass a and then a little bit of water
and put it into your HRM capable
thermocycler to go ahead and run pcr and
at the end of the PCR protocol there's
this post amplification melt this post
amplification melt is a instrument that
then raises ramps the temperature over
time and this ramping over time then
allows you to then melt the DNA measure
the TM and that identified unique
products that have been formed during
the piece of process and then if there
are the presence of snips or insertions
or deletions what ends up happening is
that you can actually then distinguish
those by their teams of differences and
so which you can see above data point
or there is that these different curves
then represent different genotypes so
there's been a change in the DNA
sequence within melt at a different
temperature so why would you use this
technique what are the advantages
inherently and one of them of course is
that you can do a broad selection of
targets i'ma spend some time showing you
exactly i'm the breadth of the targets
that you can then design assays for
their relatively fast pcr reactions
overall you can do very short cycling
times and fast ramp rate so that it
decreases the amount of the protocol
time and the data analysis is highly
scalable so that you can do as few as
just a single sample at a time up to
very large numbers quite easily and
during the data analysis so it's a very
scalable solution depending on how many
samples that you're trying to use it as
a single time so what are some of those
use cases and I wanted to talk about
that so when you think about all the
different types of genetic and
epigenetic targets I've tried to list
out all of those that you can design HRM
a sage against and some of those will be
for instance the single nucleotide
polymorphisms so sniffs you can design
those you can also do things against
somatic mutations there's examples of
insertions and deletions this could be
very small for instance maybe six
nucleotides or then you can also do
unique targets for instance those
variations that are within the
mitochondria you can do copy number
measurements within copy number
measurements there are examples of
measuring the copy number four hole
genes and then finally because of
bisulfite conversion of CPG nucleotides
you can actually look for methylated
targets and so you can even do
epigenetic analysis using HRM so really
wide range of different targets that you
can employ the HRM technology again I'm
going to show some of those to you and
in these examples so one of them is an
example of mitochondrial targets and
what you can see here is this gene me la
sits in the mitochondrial genome
it's a syndrome for mitochondrial
myopathy encephalopathy lactic acid
acidosis and stroke-like episodes and
genetically heterogeneous phenotypes
result clinically and what you can see
here is that you can actually been
distinguished it's mutation that's in
the mitochondrial genome from the wild
type and I've actually blown that up in
the next slide so that you can
distinguish these a little bit better so
what you see here in the black is this
is the wild type and then what you can
see is that there's a variance here in
the red so this would be the homozygous
mutant form of the at the locus and in
the blue sorry I've got this one wrong
way the blue line represents the
heterozygous really one is present so
really neat example of using a HRM
assays to detect my patients in the
mitochondria but one of the
flexibilities that you can have with HRM
assays that you can actually detect a
number of closely spaced mutation so in
this particular case this is in the fe h
fe team this is linked to an iron
storage disorder and I know that the
figure on the right is difficult to see
so I've blown it up here so that you can
actually not only see one mutation but
you can actually detect the other
mutation here as well and this is
important because the 187 mutation from
the feed orgy and then 193 mutation are
the two most common mutations or two of
the most common mutations in the HFA ET
mettre lead to this disease and so what
you can again see mom will try to point
things out with the arrows is for
instance this black curve here
represents what would be the wild-type
at both positions and then you can see
in the different colors for instance in
this light blue you can see a
heterozygous mutation at one position in
agreeing you can see a heterozygous at
another mutation and then you can also
see the homozygous at both positions and
so this can be often very difficult to
design a phase against when you're doing
for instance hydrolysis pro
line or other Pro based designs and in
this particular case it's quite easy to
do because you're looking at the entire
amplicon and once and then
distinguishing by these melting
temperatures now I've seen that there
have been a couple of questions that
have come in so I'm going to try and
address those now since they've come in
so the first question how does this
compare to using another trans medics
for genotype can you multiplex Lewis I
in a single sample submission and is
this can't quite see the risk this
question ah sorry can you multiplex
lo-fi in a single sample submission and
is this a service so this isn't really a
service you obviously i think this
example really calls that out though
where you can multiplex lo sai together
even in a single assay so there are two
separate mutations that are occurring
both are relevant for disease and in a
single tube because you see both
distinguish both of these from the wild
type and then another question that came
in would just be helpful in
differentiating the presence or absence
of a structural variant I'd like to show
you some data in the upcoming slides
that will address that question great
question all right so when we talk about
insertions and deletions I'm talking
about relatively small ones in this
particular case I'm talking about the
insertion of a single nucleotide in the
GBA gene this is responsible for go
share disease oh it's a lysosomal
storage disorder it's also been
associated with Parkinson's disease and
I'm going to go ahead and blow this up
again so that you can see it in a nice
detail again you can see I'm going to go
ahead and point to this here this black
line represents the wild type and then
of course if you were homozygous with
the mutation you can see the red and
then homozygous or heterozygous rather
are represented by this blue curve and
so they're quite easy to distinguish
with one another and you can see that
you can do this on a per sample basis
now this would represent a small
insertion
and now the example I'm showing you is
Nelson it's slightly bigger than the
aldo be Jean we're now it's actually a
four base pair of deletion here and you
can again see that there's a wild type
curve mutation at both alleles and then
of course the heterozygous here and so
these are both small and insertions and
deletions but I think what's really
exciting about this that's not possibly
using some of the other pro based
technologies are now tackling very large
variations so in Thai fax disease there
are mutations in the hex a gene one of
which that's really well annotated is
the 7.6 kilobase deletion and in a
single tube using a single asset you can
go ahead and see the presence of that
and I'll show you here this black
represents the wild-type at both
positions and then the sort of blue
color here this would represent the
heterozygous what's exciting about this
is of course is this would represent
that there is 170 nap till abates
deletion on one chromosome arm but the
other is wild-type and then of course if
you have a deletion in both copies you
would have this variant homozygous and
of course these are very large deletions
it's very difficult to design Probe
assays again system this is generally
tackled by using a sequencing technology
that could take you to a little bit
longer to perform or not be quite so
easy to quickly analyze so I've shown
you a lot of the different sort of
targets are available to you so it's a
very flexible technology I didn't show
you any examples of the epigenetic
modifications which you can also do
design acids again throws as well so one
of the benefits that I would argue for
high-resolution melting of course is
then the ability to attack these
different targets and interrogate them
but there are a couple of others that I
would like to point out one is the time
to results it does pcr enzymes do vary
according to protocols but in general
acids that have been designed by Canon
biomedical support to set pieces are
with about 10
cycles so that doesn't include the ramp
rate so you can imagine that very
quickly you can get through in a less
than hour genotype result for a
particular sample but one of the things
that I think is really very nice about
this is that it's really an absolute
sort of analysis it's really different
than a lot of the other pcr-based
technologies that rely strictly on
clustering to make a genotype call so
this would be a typical figure that you
would see in a genotype experiment for
instance for hydrolysis probes or more
commonly known as tack mangroves you can
see that there are these clusters of the
different genotypes so the genotype in
red would represent a homozygous for one
particular allele the in the blue there
would represent the homozygote for the
other allele and then the heterozygous
would then be shown there in the black
in this sort of center cluster and then
in the bottom left-hand corner than the
note a template control with no DNA is
added to the reaction so when a new
sample would be then be tested within
fall within one of these clusters so
that you have been be able to call its
genotype but there aren't some
inherently very difficult things that
can occur in this and because of this
clustering here what you can see is that
for instance just by changing the for
instance the scale on an axis based off
of the fluorescent signal that is
captured during the PCR run it could
actually end up misleading you into
calling the wrong genotype so on the
left hand of figure you can see the same
clustering and then there would be the
gray dots that would represent the no
template control over here and then we
have this nice cluster down here in the
blue and then we have this sort of dark
blue black triangle that's in the upper
portion of the figure until you would
immediately begin all based off of the
previous figure you'd say well maybe
that's a heterozygous and it's not
really with the homozygous and what you
can see though is that if you did
additional samples in the analysis that
it Reese kales the y-axis and so the
fluorescent signal now here has changed
rather dramatically in what you would
see is that original sort of dark
blue triangle actually is very close to
the rest of the cluster here and it
actually then represents the homozygous
for one of the alleles and if I the
addition of more samples that you were
able then clearly distinguish the
heterozygous so an insufficient number
of samples in your experiment because
the clustering could then result in not
scaling the axis appropriately and you
could actually end up with making the
wrong genotype call so you're sort of
safeguarded only if you use enough
samples in your experiment let's look at
another example though when you're doing
samples a lot of times genotyping
experiments you do a few samples as they
come into laboratory then you get some
more for instance our rolling basis for
apps you're only going to process so
many at a time by limitations of for
instance the size of the plate in your
instrument and one of the challenges
that presents is that you can't really
combine data together you have to do
each individual experiments and analyze
the data within that experiment and so
what I'm showing here then our two
individual experiments that have been
run on different days using samples that
represent the homozygous heteros I in
homozygote variant and you can see they
in each individual experiments they
cluster quite nicely but if you were to
try to combine those datasets you then
end up with a really large number of
different clusters that didn't become
very very difficult to discriminate
against and that would then require you
know for instance run a number of n you
know samples all at the same time and
that makes it very difficult and this is
all contrasted with for instance high
resolution melting analysis which is as
I said before it's really an absolute
data analysis so it scales whether it's
a small number of samples for instance
is small a single sample that you can
look at the TM values up to hundreds if
not thousands of samples that you could
run in very very large experiments
because you have these very distinct
peaks it then have associated melting
temperatures so you could even run
controls the compare a single sample
against and then once you know for
instance the profile the melting profile
for your individual variations you could
very easily be able to call individual
ones so are we
only basis this is very scalable but if
you have large number it's a very fast
technology to be able to get through all
of these samples I did see another
question that came in for amplification
of repetitive regions how is this
impacting the high resolution mouth I e
transpose ax bilello meant sore
microsatellite repeat that's a great
question there are certainly attempts at
trying to deal with this because these
repetitive regions could then change
your amplification product length which
we then change your melting temperature
there are some examples of that have
been attempted in some very like
specific examples I believe if i'm not
mistaken i think there's an example with
a fragile exit has been attempted be
called through high-resolution melting
analysis that's been paired with
real-time pcr in a paper and i'll
certainly try for those of you that are
requesting the slides i'll try to
provide some footnote as to what that
paper would be so in summary i think HRM
acids enable you to test for a really
broad range of genetic variations they
deliver a very fast reaction so you get
your results sooner and the data
analysis is very simple you can do just
one sample at a time or you can do very
very large sample numbers and so tandem
biomedical has generated a library of
assays and chemistry focused on using
high-resolution melton analysis we call
them the no galil acids in chemistry so
new allele and they're available they're
compatible with virtually any HRM
compatible a thermocycler we ship our a
phasing master mix under environmental
conditions so there's no additional ice
packs or things to deal with and you can
store them just in the refrigerator so
you don't even have to carve out freezer
space for them if you've already
designed your own HRM assays you
certainly can use our 2x mobile all go
dilution buffer to go ahead and dilute
those all of those and then use it with
our rapid PCR chemistry and we have our
website so you can either
browse or search for individual snips of
interest in human biology we have a
discover section our website that's
arranged by human biology so cancer
immune to the immune disease infectious
disease all of these are human variants
that in some way impact human biology or
you can search for individual variants
by either gene or RSI p clinvar number
you could search for the for instance if
there's a pharmacogenetic association
you could even search by a particular
drug that's associated with individual
snips to look at what are the snips that
impact their drug response so in
conclusion I'm happy to introduce cane
and biomedical as your new partner in
biomedical research we're already doing
on blowing collaborations as i showed in
the beginning of the talk with other
companies we're interested in working
with universities and we're already at a
couple of universities sharing some of
our technologies and working towards
advancing their research to support
human genetic research we've launched
last year the Nova little assays in
chemistry so these are assays for rapid
pcr that are doing coupled with
high-resolution melting analysis and
it's an optimized chemistry they can
deliver genotyping results in under an
hour we have a lot more coming out later
this year we're going to be very excited
to share that with you as it comes out
and so with that I'm go ahead and close
i'm going to leave up first here's the
questions I'm happy to take any
additional questions that you have we
have a booth here at lab roots we
encourage you to stop by we have
additional materials there that you can
download and there's our email address
our website and our phone number we're
happy to have you reach out and talk to
us and see if we can help you with your
experiment and at this point i'd like to
go ahead and launch my last poll which
would be how many of you would like it
me to send you a copy of the slides and
I'd be happy to do that so if we can go
ahead and launch that poll for the
duration of the talk and happy to send
you those slides after today and
whatever other questions that you have
about the technology and how we've
approached it or who came to biomedical
is and our other interests I'd be happy
to take those questions now so thank you
very very much
thank you Brian for that informative
presentation it's time for Q&A if you
have a question you'd like to ask Brian
please do so now just click on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the send button and we'll
give you a few moments to do that maybe
you're answering the poll
if there are no more questions I would
like to once again to thank Brian for
his presentation do you have any final
comments you'd like to share with us
today right well I certainly appreciate
everyone's time today listening to sort
of Cana biomedical and introducing
ourselves to the biomedical research
audience one of the questions that sort
of i'm often asked when i come different
presentations regarding this technology
is really you know it's you know how
scalable it is and i really wanted to
spend a lot of time there on the data
analysis because we do find that that is
one of the things that's actually very
very easy about having pre-formatted
assays that have sort of known
characteristics and so if you go onto
our website you can see for instance the
melts curves that are associated with
each of those different relevant
mutations so I encourage you to check
that out and with that them i think i'd
like to go ahead and close well thank
you again Ryan I would also like to
thank our sponsor ten in biomedical for
making today's webcast possible this is
an educational webinar and thus offers
free continuing education credits after
the webinar is over and get your CD
credits just click on the CD button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your web page before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through November 12 2016 you'll receive
an email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay we share that announcement with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon right